the justice department remains committed
to holding all january 6 perpetrators
at any level
accountable under law
whether they were present that day
or were otherwise criminally responsible
for the assault on our democracy
we will follow the facts
wherever they lead
that was u.s attorney general merrick
garland last week responding to
criticism that he was moving too slowly
and prosecuting the major players in
last year's january 6 attack on the u.s
capitol last night the u.s justice
department filed the toughest
indictments yet
they included the charge that many
democrats had been calling for seditious
conspiracy
that's when two or more people conspire
to overthrow put down or destroy by
force the government of the united
states
the indictments they mark a serious
escalation in the january 6th
investigation after more than 700
arrests this is the first use of the
sedition charge which carries a 20-year
maximum prison term and it's been
leveled against the most high-profile
defendants so far stewart rhodes founder
and leader of the far-right oath keeper
militia groups rhodes along with 10
other members and associates stand
accused of plotting to storm the capitol
by force to prevent joe biden
from becoming u.s president
well my first guest tonight is the man
who literally wrote the book on the oath
keeper sam jackson is an assistant
professor at the university of albany
and he is an expert in right-wing
extremism in the u.s he's the author of
the book oath keepers patriotism and the
edge of violence in a right-wing
anti-government group
professor jackson it's good to have you
on the day let me ask you what did you
think when you heard the news that the
fbi had arrested oath keepers founder
stewart robes
to be honest i i wasn't entirely
expecting this indictment or that arrest
to happen
traditionally stewart rhodes has been
pretty risk-averse and he's been pretty
adept at avoiding
too much legal scrutiny directed at
himself
it seemed based on the public
information that i had seen before
yesterday's indictment that he might
have been successful in doing so again
regarding the january 6th attack but as
we now know um the the department of
justice has plenty of information
regarding his involvement or his alleged
involvement i should say in planning for
the criminal activities that both
keepers engaged in on that day
we understand there are an estimated 38
000 members of oath keepers across the
u.s
these are what former military and
police
officers also like stewart rhodes
they're well educated some of them are
even ivy league graduates i mean this is
a different level of threat that we are
looking at
or or or is it not how would you
describe it
it's a little bit difficult to assess um
what we might think of as demographic
information about oath keepers
the group has long claimed more than 30
or 35 000 dues paying members the
watchdog organizations like the
anti-defamation league and the southern
poverty law center have estimated that
there's no more than a few thousand
active dues paying members at any given
moment it's also not clear how much of
the membership actually has experience
in military or law enforcement
certainly the group organizes around
this idea that it tries to recruit and
is primarily made up of people with such
service
but the group also welcomes people
without such service and it's just
really difficult for us to know
how many of its members have that
service how many of its members have
education and what types of education
that sort of granular information is
just not publicly available
we noticed that in the indictment it
reads that rhodes urged people to march
in mass to the nation's capital like the
people of serbia did 20 years ago can
you tell us anything about
that serbian connection here
as an organization oath keepers as well
as stewart roads individually are are
very fond of searching for historical
precedents for their understanding of
the world that they find themselves in
and for the crises that they perceive
more commonly they will point to the
american revolutionary war or the war
from independence from great britain to
find those historical precedents but
they have also pointed to as you say um
conflicts in the balkans they've pointed
to world war ii um and resistance to uh
the nazi regime to try to find
precedence for the activity that they're
uh
involved in or planning for or the
different events that they perceive i
don't think that necessarily means
there's any formal connection that the
group has
with participants in that balkan's
conflict though
um the oath keepers they often refer to
the founding fathers of the united
states
thomas jefferson for example he was an
advocate of generational renewal saying
that each generation must conduct its
own revolution
but why are we talking about this and
the oath keepers now in the 21st century
there's a long history in america of
um different
uh people with different political views
political identities um fighting over
the legacy of those founding fathers um
there's an excellent book um the
author's name is eluding me the book is
called the jefferson rule which talks
about how even the founders themselves
fought over the their own legacy in the
decades after the nation was founded so
this is nothing new to try to claim that
legacy and to try to
look to their writing to inform
contemporary politics oathkeepers has
found a particularly pernicious way to
do this in their indications of violence
and in their justifications for violence
but it's certainly not confined to them
in in your book you you also note that
militias like the oath keepers have
increased in numbers and in members
since 2008 that's when barack obama
became
u.s president that i'm wondering how
much of this is connected
to
to white supremacy and to the fears of
whites being replaced by minorities in
the united states is that driving this
surge in in membership
this is actually a really difficult
question that you're asking
um and and one that is the subject of
lively debate among researchers on this
field my own view is that
oath keepers as an organization is not
organized around perceived racial
identity
it is not an organization that is
motivated around perceived whiteness or
perceived threats to whiteness however
it is certainly the case
that people who are motivated by a
perceived racial identity can find uh
common cause with individuals uh within
the oath keepers organization and may
even join themselves the oath keepers
organization is organized around a
perception that government is tyrannical
and a desire to push back against that
perceived tyrannical government
this is something that racists have also
put forward
in other contexts in american history so
it's certainly familiar in that sense
but i think it is um overly simplistic
and uh
to to try to depict oath keepers as an
organization as part of a broader white
supremacist movement within the u.s yeah
it's fascinating on what you're saying
there and i wish we had more time to
talk about this
more in depth mr jackson but i'm sure
that we will have the opportunity to
talk again
sam jackson assistant presser professor
at the university of albany and author
of the book oath keepers patriotism and
the edge of violence in a right-wing
anti-government group professor jackson
we appreciate your time and your
insights tonight thank you
thank you